oh we are
here
what is your spirit should it get me this to try
you know I like them better our four mothers gave
us its fear because it is precise elegant and
completely
it will not change under my watch
stop right there who are you and how did you get
in here this place is amazing the air is pristine
underwater my mother told stories about
a place like this a protected land with
people that never had to leave
never have to change who they were
what reason do you have to rebuild your
secret to the world I am not a woman who
enjoys or repeating herself who argue
I had many names my people called me
get out of my dorm get out hey I'm warning
you do not take another step toward me
see how they teach the
children to treat their guests
I like it hey hey hey hey put it down put it you
hit yourself come on it's all right princess small
small girl I am going to give you two options
you can come to wakanda conscious or unconscious
is it a way that you look around
here all that Ash on your head
your head oh it's funny no it's not I told you
you look good. Welcome back everyone it's Charlie
this will be my new black panther wakanda forever
trailer video there's a whole bunch of extended
clips that they released too so we'll break it
all down there's just a whole bunch of Easter
eggs a whole bunch of stuff to talk about if
you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos because the movie
is coming out really soon we're doing a giveaway
for IMAX tickets all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and just post all your theories
based on the footage in the video I'm supposed
to be seeing the movie in the next week so if I
get a chance to see it early I will post a review
video as soon as they let us do that I know there
are a bunch of questions about what's going on
with the characters like what is the future of
Namor what's the future of the New Black Panther
which seems like it's pretty much confirmed it's
going to be shuri now did a lot of questions
about what's going on with Doctor Doom in the
MCU because it seems like they're invoking a
lot of Doom War elements from the comics where
he basically goes after wakanda because of their
vibranium the report so far is that there is no
actual Doctor Doom walking around in the movie
which I think is in line with our expectations
like this is all about setting up Namor his
people the Atlanta in the MCU which they're
calling Tallow can and setting up the future of
shuri's black panther so there's already just
so much stuff going on in this and they set up a
bunch of other stuff as well as you would expect
each Marvel movie because there's a bunch of black
panther spin-offs that they're going to be doing
on Disney plus and series like a wakanda Forever
series this is supposed to be in akoye series just
for her as well so based on reports it sounds like
what they've done is that you have Doctor Doom in
the background just kind of pulling strings but
nobody actually mentions the name Doctor Doom in
the movie as far as we know one of the big ideas
in the movie is that Namor's people are threatened
because you have this research team of regular
humans looking for vibranium in underwater places
and that's how they find his City like the teams
that are going after vibranium in the underwater
lab here all the humans seem like they're working
for Lake Bell's character who I believe is playing
a version of Lucia Von Bardas one of Doctor Doom's
Chief lieutenants from latveria and that's one of
the only references we actually get to Doctor Doom
legit in the movie like reference to her character
in her backstory so it seems like he's trying to
find vibranium and using this team team but we
don't actually find out that it's really him who's
behind everything until a little bit later in the
MCU in some Future movie or Disney plus series
they did just screen the movie and there was only
one post-credit scene so no spoilers for what was
actually in that but typically Marvel movies have
two post credit scenes like there's a mid-credits
scene and an actual post-credits scene so a lot of
people are wondering if they're going to add a
second post-credit scene after the movie comes
out in theaters and they didn't show it to critics
or to people who saw it early because it's such a
big spoiler and that could be a Doctor Doom scene
but I'm not going to hold my breath on it they did
the same thing when the very first Avengers movie
came out like they waited to like literally the
last possible second when the movie came out
in theaters to add that Shawarma scene where
they're all eating Shawarma together reportedly
there'll be more stuff going on with Doctor Doom
more Easter eggs for him in the background when
we get to the Iron Heart series because obviously
black panther wakanda forever also setting up the
ironheart series mostly because the storyline in
ironheart is going to be all about Magic versus
technology and that's core Doctor Doom territory
like he's a man of science and a man of magic I
know there's all kinds of questions too because
cause it seems like Sasha Baron Cohen is going
to be playing a version of Mephisto during that
Series so what they might do long term like early
Theory it'd be really cool if they did it if they
set up a triumphant torment Arc for Doctor Doom
in the MCU if you don't know that story that's the
storyline where Dr Strange and Doctor Doom team
up to fight Mephisto and hell to try and rescue
Doctor Doom's mother they saw the Mephisto memes
they're like okay you want a version of Mephisto
we'll give you a version of Mephisto use it to
picture MCU Doctor Doom punching Sasha Baron
Cohen in the face as Mephisto you will never get
this you will never get this here behind this cage
crazy crazy everybody laughs but talking about
the new footage here I know there's a question
about these two black panther helmets these are
actually the previous helmets worn by t'challa's
Black Panther in what seems like one of his
tombs or a monument to him the one on the left
was t'challa's original black panther suit that he
wore in Captain America Civil War and the second
one on the right is the one that shuri gave him
during the Black Panther movie that he wore all
the way through Avengers end game you get a whole
bunch more footage of the characters more footage
of Riri Williams ironheart in her Mark 1 and then
her with shuri building her Mark too obviously the
Mark 1 looks much more like it's inspired by
Iron Man's armor suits like she dumpster Dives
it together it looks all cobbled together the
Arc Reactor is the same shape as Iron Man's arc
reactors but then when they're making the Mark II
like the vibranium Iron Heart suit her Arc Reactor
actually starts looking more like the actual heart
where she gets her name from Iron Heart they have
a couple clips of her testing out her Arc Reactor
technology which is meant to be a mirror for Iron
Man testing out his Arc Reactor technology just
kind of derping all over the place just hurting
himself trying to figure out the problems it
looks similar to Iron Man's arc reactors but
just a little bit different like you get the idea
like they want it to be inspired by Iron Man but
it's not just meant to be a straight up copy of
Iron Man's technology we get a much longer scene
of shuri in her new black panther suit showing us
what it looks like in an extended fight scene like
it almost seems like she's defying the laws of
physics just because of the extra abilities that
her suit has and like you would expect every time
they upgrade an armored suit it gets even more
Powers I think a good comparison to make would be
in the difference between Iron Man's armors later
on through Avengers Infinity war and Avengers
end game so like t'challa's last black panther
suit did have nanites in it it worked a little
bit like Iron Man's suit with the way it formed
around him but it seems like what sure he's done
is taken that a step further and it's much closer
to the difference between Iron Man's previous
armors and his Infinity war and end game armor
where her new black panther suit can literally
make anything around her that she might need
any kind of weapons any kind of Technology like
it forms the panther hand cannons that she use
during the first Black Panther movie but they
just format of nanites so they go away when she
doesn't need them then there's a clip of name
or actually flooding wakanda during their big
Invasion and obviously there's a big Easter egg
for the more recent Phoenix Arc where a bunch of
different characters got the powers of the Phoenix
Namor uses it to trump Black Panther and get a
big one up on him in their long-standing beef by
completely flooding wakanda killing a whole bunch
of people the difference in this clip is that it
seems like they used a lot of the rivers and the
inlets because there's that other clip where a
Namor meets shuri in ramonda for the first time
and they're like how did you get in here where did
you come from who are you it seems like they're
either hanging out on the riverfront or near a
bay and he just got in using the river he got an
underwater under the shield at a weak point and
because he's covered in vibranium it sounds like
this clip is happening earlier in the movie and
he's approaching them because of what's happened
with this research team coming upon his City like
all these Invaders are coming for us now and it
has something to do with what you did revealing
wakanda to the world why did you do that he also
kind of explains his people's backstory during
this too when he's talking to them wait a minute
you never had to hide or change who you were I
think part of the idea is that they'll have some
sort of flashback or something during the movie to
reference what actually happened to his people and
why genetically they mutated talking about mutants
going underwater because getting to the X-Men the
mutants of it all Namor is going to be a mutant
in the MCU that's why he has the wings on his feet
that's why he can fly and if it wasn't clear all
of his people's weapons all the metal jewelry on
him all the metal pieces are all made of vibranium
that just fell underwater look the whole idea in
the comics is that vibranium exists other places
on the planet not just in wakanda it's just the
biggest concentration of it is in wakanda they
have another scene of Okoye and shuri coming to
rescue Riri Williams and her just being freaked
out and then akoye making fun of Riri Williams
you can be conscious or unconscious that's a
bit of a reference to the Black Widow versus
Dora milaje seen in Captain America Civil War
like the same energy where they had their own
little ultimatum you will move or be moved you
have another scene of akoye getting pissed at
Anika when the dora milaje are fighting off those
Invaders In the vibranium lab Anika is from the
comics she's being played by Michaela Cole she's
also part of the midnight Angels which is like
the special fighting force inside the door milage
like even more hardcore group within their group
for trying out her energy daggers in their fight
instead of using the vibranium Spears which Okoye
yells about being their traditional weapons and
because she's in charge of the door milaje they're
not going to be changing their Traditions anytime
soon under her watch I think that's meant to flow
with the whole storyline about the selection of
who the next Black Panther winds up being because
it's not immediately decided that is going to be
Sharia that isn't the first thing that everybody
goes to there's a big question about who has the
right to be the next Black Panther and I think
that becomes a larger discussion about what the
traditions of the Black Panther character itself
within wakanda are like how do we choose the next
Black Panther what is the role of the next Black
Panther you also have to remember that shuri is
about the same age as Peter Parker in the MCU so
even though she seems a little bit older she's
actually still pretty young if you spotted any
other big Easter eggs in the trailer footage or
the clips that I didn't talk about in the video
or my previous Black Panther videos just write
them Below in the comments and like I said if
I do get a chance to see the movie early in the
next week before it comes out I will do a review
early everyone click here for my full Ant-Man
and the wasp Quantumania trailer video and
Kang Easter eggs and click here for my house of
the dragon alternate ending and deleted scenes
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!